>>> BRITTANY, SHE CHOSE TO GET
MARRIED, CHOSE TO TAKE TRIPS ALL
AROUND THE WORLD.
AND AFTER BEING DIAGNOSED WITH
TERMINAL BRAIN CANCER AT THE AGE
OF 29, BRITTANY CHOOSES TO DIE.
JUST AFTER SHE WAS MARRIED LAST
YEAR, BRITTANY BEGAN
EXPERIENCING THESE DEBILITATING
HEADACHES.
DOCTORS EVENTUALLY TELLING HER
SHE HAD SIX PAINFUL MONTHS LEFT.
SO BRITTANY TOOK HER LIFE AND IS
TAKING HER DEATH IN HER OWN
HANDS.
SHE AND HER FAMILY MOVED TO
OREGON, ONE OF ONLY FIVE U.S.
STATES ALLOWING HER TO USE THIS
PRESCRIPTION DRUG THAT WILL KILL
HER.
HERE'S PART OF HER STORY.
>> SO AFTER GETTING MARRIED IS
WHEN I FIRST STARTED
EXPERIENCING THE HEADACHES.
AND THEY WERE QUITE SEVERE.
AND I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THEM
BECAUSE I HAD NEVER HAD ANYTHING
LIKE THAT BEFORE IN MY LIFE.
RIGHT WHEN I WAS DIAGNOSED, MY
HUSBAND AND I WERE ACTIVELY
TRYING FOR A FAMILY, WHICH IS
HEARTBREAKING FOR US BOTH.
AND THEN I WAS DIAGNOSED THIS
PAST NEW YEAR'S.
WE WENT AWAY TO THE WINE COUNTRY
FOR A NEW YEAR'S EVE
CELEBRATION.
THE FOLLOWING DAY I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER AND TOLD I
WAS TERMINALLY ILL.
TOLD ANYWHERE FROM THREE, MAYBE
FIVE, UP TO TEN YEARS TO LIVE.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU WHEN YOU'RE
29 YEARS OLD, BEING TOLD YOU
HAVE THAT KIND OF TIME LINE
STILL FEELS LIKE YOU'RE BEING
TOLD YOU'RE GOING TO DIE
TOMORROW.
70 DAYS POST OP I WENT IN FOR
ANOTHER MRI AND WAS TOLD I HAD A
CHANGE.
THEY WERE SAYING IT LOOKS LIKE
GRADE 4, WHICH IS THE WORST AND
MOST AGGRESSIVE FORM OF BRAIN
CANCER.
THAT WAS A MAJOR SHOCK TO MY
SYSTEM AND SYSTEM OF MY FAMILY,
BECAUSE I WENT FROM HAVING
POTENTIALLY YEARS OF TIME TO
BEING TOLD I HAD LIKE SIX
MONTHS.
I KNOW IT'S THERE WHEN I NEED
IT.
I PLAN TO BE SURROUNDED BY MY
IMMEDIATE FAMILY, WHICH IS MY
HUSBAND AND MY MOTHER AND MY
STEPFATHER AND MY BEST FRIEND
WHO IS ALSO A PHYSICIAN.
PROBABLY NOT MUCH MORE PEOPLE.
AND I WILL DIE UPSTAIRS IN MY
BEDROOM THAT I SHARE WITH MY
HUSBAND, MY MOTHER AND MY
HUSBAND BY MY SIDE.
AND PASS PEACEFULLY WITH SOME
MUSIC I LIKE IN THE BACKGROUND.
I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU THE AMOUNT
OF RELIEF TO PROVIDE ME TO KNOW
THAT I DON'T HAVE TO DIE THE WAY
IT'S BEEN DESCRIBED TO ME THAT
MY BRAIN TUMOR WOULD TAKE ME ON
ITS OWN.
I HOPE TO ENJOY HOWEVER MANY
DAYS I HAVE LEFT ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL EARTH AND SPEND AS
MUCH OF IT OUTSIDE AS I CAN
SURROUNDED BY THOSE I LOVE.
I HOPE TO PASS IN PEACE.
THE REASON TO CONSIDER LIFE AND
WHAT'S OF VALUE IS TO MAKE SURE
YOU'RE NOT MISSING OUT.
SEIZE THE DAY, WHAT'S IMPORTANT
TO YOU, WHAT DO YOU CARE ABOUT
WHAT MATTERS?
PURSUE THAT, FORGET THE REST.
>> KENNETH GOODMAN, FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
MIAMI AND CODIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY'S ETHICS PROGRAM.
WELCOME TO YOU.
I MEAN, JUST READING AND
WATCHING HER ENTIRE VIDEO, IT'S
PRETTY STUNNING.
IT'S EMOTIONAL AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL ONE DAY
CAN RELATE TO.
BUT IN SOME CASES ALL TOO SOON.
SO I HAVE A LOT FOR YOU,
INCLUDING THIS DEATH WITH
DIGNITY.
THE LAWS, KENNETH.
BUT FIRST, BEFORE WE TAKE A
QUICK BREAK.
WATCHING THIS VIDEO AND SEEING
BRITTANY SHOW EVERYONE THIS PILL
SHE WALKS AROUND WITH IN HER
WALLET.
TO ME, THAT SAYS THE CHOICE IS
IN HER OWN HANDS ANY TIME SHE
WANTS.
>> IT DOES.
AND IT SHOWS HOW PEOPLE
SOMETIMES FIND MEANING IN THEIR
LIVES BY PLANNING FOR THEIR
DEMISE.
IT'S A TERRIBLE -- AND THIS
WOMAN HAS CHOSEN TO TAKE THIS
COURSE IN A STATE THAT DOES
PERMIT IT.
PEOPLE FIND MEANING FOR THEIR
LIFE IN LOTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS MAKE
LIFE WITH A PRESCRIPTION PILL ON
THE 1st OF NOVEMBER.
SHE HAS A DATE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT HER FAMILY HERE?
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> MY PARENTS SPENT A COUPLE OF
MONTHS, JUST LOOKING FOR A
MIRACLE.
>> I HOPED FOR EVERYTHING.
FIRST, I HOPED THEY HAD THE
WRONG X-RAYS, THE WRONG SET OF
SCANS, IT WAS ALL A BIT CLERICAL
MISHAP.
YOUR BRAIN WILL DO REALLY
STRANGE THINGS TO YOU WHEN YOU
DON'T WANT TO BELIEVE SOMETHING.
YOU WILL COME UP WITH FAIRY
TALES.
>> -- FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
PREDICAMENT OF FACING A LOT OF
SUFFERING THAT THEY CAN DECIDE
WHEN ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
>> MY HOPE NOW IS THAT MY
DAUGHTER CAN LIVE HER LIFE THE
WAY SHE WANTS TO, THAT SHE CAN
MAKE THE DECISIONS SHE WANTS TO
BE WHO SHE IS, WHICH IS THIS
VERY AUTONOMOUS, BRIGHT WELL
READ, WELL TRAVELED PERSON WHO
LOVES ADVENTURE.
SHE KIND OF GOT ME INTO THIS
THING WHERE WE'VE AGREED TO
MEET.
AND SO I'M GOING TO GO ON A
TRAVELING ADVENTURE.
AND THIS PLACE I'M KIND OF
SCARED TO GO TO.
A LOT OF CLIMBING, BUT SHE SAID
SHE'D MEET ME THERE.
AND SO I'LL GO.
>> SHE'S GOING TO GO MEET HER
DAUGHTER AS HER DAUGHTER HAS NOT
MUCH TIME LEFT.
FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI'S CODE AND
ETHICS PROGRAMS.
FIRST OF MANY QUESTIONS I HAVE
FOR YOU HERE IS, OBVIOUSLY, THE
MOTHER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT TOOK.
TO GET THE MOTHER AND STEPFATHER
ON BOARD WITH THIS PLANE, TO
TAKE THIS FATAL PILL THE FIRST
OF NOVEMBER.
BUT I HAVE TO IMAGINE YOU'VE
SEEN OR HEARD OF OTHER INSTANCES
WHERE OTHER, YOU KNOW, CLOSE
LOVED ONES DISAGREE WITH THE
PLAN.
>> INDEED, THEY DO.
THESE DECISIONS ARE AMONG THE
MOST EXQUISITELY DIFFICULT IN
THE HISTORY OF CIVILIZATION.
ONE OF THEM IS THAT LIFE IS
PRECIOUS, SO IS LIBERTY.
AND WHEN A FAMILY MEMBER IS
NEARING DEATH, IT COULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO SORT OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IS.
HAVING THE FAMILY ON BOARD, AND
INTERESTING EXPERIMENT ALONG
WITH THE OTHER STATES.
>> SO HERE SHE IS, THOUGH.
WHAT ELSE IS STRUGGLING IN THE
VIDEO, YOU SEE HER WITH THE PILL
IN HER WALLET, CUTS TO THE
PICTURE OF HER BEDROOM WHERE
SHE'S PLANNING ON PASSING DOWN
TO THE MUSIC SHE'LL BE PLAYING
IN THE BACKGROUND, DOWN TO WHICH
LOVED ONE SHE WANTS BY HER SIDE.
IS THAT -- I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY
OF THIS IS TYPICAL, PERIOD, BUT
IS THIS MORE OR LESS HOW THIS IS
DONE?
>> NOW -- ONE REASONABLE
RESPONSE TO THAT IS THIS IS A
LITTLE TMI.
WE MAY SUPPORT ONE'S RIGHT TO
SEEK ASSISTANCE IN DYING, BUT IN
FACT, LIKE MANY OTHER MEDICAL
FACTS, TREATMENTS AND HUMAN
RESPONSES TO THOSE, IT'S
PROBABLY BEST TO KEEP THEM
PRIVATE.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE NOTION THAT
THIS IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE?
THERE'S A WHOLE DEBATE THAT THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" IS PROVIDING,
JUST QUICKLY HERE ON HOW SOME
PEOPLE HAVE UNDIAGNOSED
DEPRESSION AND HOW THEY WANT
THESE PILLS FOR THE WRONG
REASONS.
THE DOCTOR DOESN'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THE PATIENT'S CONDITION,
MAYBE THE PATIENT DOESN'T NEED
ONE OF THESE PILLS, BUT IN
OREGON, FOR EXAMPLE, IT'S
PERFECTLY LEGAL.
YOUR RESPONSE.
>> SO ONE OF THE THINGS THEY DID
IN OREGON, INITIALLY AND OTHER
STATES HAVE TRIED TO EMULATE IS
PUT IN PLACE SAFEGUARDS TO
PREVENT EXACTLY SUCH
SLIPPERINESS ON THAT SLOPE.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU HAVE TO SHOW
SOME DURABILITY OF DESIRE.
THEY SCREEN AGAINST DEPRESSION.
THIS IS NOT A FLY BY NIGHT
ORGANIZATION.
THIS IS A RESPONSE AFTER
HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF TRYING TO
COME TO TERMS WITH TECHNOLOGY TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN IF EVER IT'S
PERMISSIBLE TO DO THIS.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE MISGIVINGS,
GOOD TO NOT THROW THE GATES WIDE
OPEN, WHICH IS WHY I REGARD AND
OTHERS, I THINK, REGARD OREGON
AS A BIT OF AN EXPERIMENT.